[Music]
foreign
were being ignored by France's teenage
looters on Friday dressed in black and
moving fast carrying out daylight
robbery at this shopping mall in the
Paris suburb of Krate
similar incidents were reported at Mars
in nearby Ronnie and ta
the French President returned early from
a summit in Brussels he urged parents to
keep their kids off the streets accused
social media companies of helping to
facilitate the violence and he condemned
the looters
there's an unacceptable exploitation of
the death of a teenager which we all
deplore this time should be about
contemplation and respect I strongly
condemn those who are using this
situation to try and create disorder and
Target our institutions a growing number
of police and gender are now deployed to
tackle any signs of disorder in central
Paris Riot police broke up a noisy but
peaceful demonstration by student groups
but elsewhere there have been more
incidents of looting and violence
the neighborhood where 17 year old nahel
M was shot dead has been quiet but tense
shopkeepers spent the day taking stock
boarding up Windows if they could
everyone hoping for the best
all this damage won't bring a solution
we have to find Democratic responses we
have to respect the law you can't just
create chaos who ends up suffering it's
the poorest it's us working people
unemployment inflation life's everyday
struggles It All Leads to situations
like this if there was Full Employment
here if young people could go to school
instead of schools shutting we'd have
less problems now M's funeral takes
place later on Saturday an opportunity
perhaps to press pause on the violence
of the past few nights but equally it
could provide just another spark for yet
more unrest
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera non-terre